What did you just say?
Leave this place.
You want to see what
the afterlife looks like or something?
More like
people in the afterlife
say that you're a nuisance.
Stupid kid!
Ryu isn't scared of any spirits!
That's right.
-If you think you can take me on--
-"Then come and get some"?
-What?
There's someone who's been
itching for a fight for a while now.
Isn't that right…
Amidamaru?
It's a spirit samurai!
I am most grateful
for this opportunity
to get revenge after such disgrace,
Master Yoh.
Don't tell me this spirit
is the owner of that broken grave,
Amidamaru!
The legendary samurai!
Hey.
Not this Amidamaru crap again.
I knew it! He's just a spirit, after all…
-Kill them!
-Yes, sir!
Okay.
Let's show them a thing or two.
-Right, Amidamaru?
-Yes.
When your technique is combined with mine,
we're invincible!
Amidamaru!
Spirit Flame Mode!
I told you, didn't I?
I connect this world with the next.
That's what a Shaman does!
Let's go!
Spirit Integrate!
The Spirit Flame is going inside his body!
Spirit Integrate?
As in possession?
Possession…
"The state of being
controlled by a spirit."
Don't tell me that's what he meant
by "joining this world with the next!"
This ought to be plenty
for the likes of you.
All right! Now it's my turn.
Are you ready?